what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit
podcast clipped clip labeled these
traits decide
if she's an f buddy or wifey material
another
feel-good clip let me tell you before i
begin do not forget to hit that
subscribe button as you guys know
20 000 subscribers is my new goal and
each and every one of you help me get to
that goal
okay and bring the notification bell
while you're at it that's gonna alert
you when i do my daily video
my um when i'm not reacting to things
live i watch everything in like 1.5 x
speed
what sets a girl apart from somebody
that i just want to [ __ ] versus somebody
that i want to date or
marry damn that's a good question yes
i mean you know if you just want to
smash it's somebody that looks good or
depending on how horny you are you know
what i'm saying
um but to be like a wife or a girlfriend
i i think the big i wouldn't want to
date any of these
like it's interesting i wonder if these
answers are going to be like just for
these guys or like
overall if guys just think the same
thing this thing that most women lack
now is like
loyalty like you know what i'm saying
that like
being loyal you know like myron always
says back in the day
women got married because of being
virgins right
now i'm not saying yo she's got to be a
virgin but
that was a big thing back in the day and
now it's like it doesn't matter she can
have a hundred bodies and she's still
gonna get wifed up you know or hobbied
up
um but i think loyalty is number one
somebody who's able to
raise your children the way that you
wanna you know them to be raised
somebody who um you know
is able to communicate in a healthy
manner
a lot of modern women nowadays that like
to gaslight a lot
i've heard that from just like talking
to different guys about how
girls can be so quick to get like super
i'm not saying y'all but i'm just saying
um somebody's mentally healthy man a lot
of narcissism
entanglement going around you know what
i'm saying and if i had to guess
i would say social media has been a big
part into the increase in narcissism and
to our society because it makes you like
think that every single thing you say is
important
so like that mental health you know can
we meditate together you know what i'm
saying
drink some tea you know what i'm saying
yeah
um but somebody you know is gonna
add on positively to your life instead
of trying to be combative or just create
chaos
so just to i just want to ask him a
question now regarding what you just
said
um now this is getting to know somebody
and that's why you want to have but what
about initial
beginning stages well beginning you want
to just
mess around with all the girls until you
get to know them and then you want to
wipe them up
or do you see something automatically i
mean it really depends on the situation
like
you know i mean obviously um you know
i'm not
big on trying to talk on the phone i
know that's the thing
texting and you know snapchatting and
instagramming
my goal is yo i'm trying to get you face
to face like
i'm trying to see what's the energy like
is there synergy or is there
opposite energy you know what i'm saying
how are we communicating
are you giving me eye contact what's
your body language like
you know but you're not gonna know off
the first night if she's
girlfriend material or you know but
don't they say menthol and
fall in love through loyalty and quality
there are certain things a woman can do
you know what i'm saying if she comes
over you know she cooks she cleans
she goes that extra mile because a lot
of girls let's keep her a lot of girls
are lazy she's like yo
here here's my phone just order some
uber eats you know what's going on
like like real talk and my boy sitting
right there well it's
interesting because he's like half the
time when they out because they always
ask girls on this show like what do you
bring to the table it's like basically
trying to show that they literally
bring nothing and half the time the
girls will say i cook and clean
and the guys will make fun of them for
it but there's this guy right here
saying that's what guys want or he wants
yeah like
he used to be a slayer i'm sorry nate i
gotta call it out but he he slayed all
types of things and
his girlfriend just stood out by just
doing the little things that matters
you know what i'm saying and a lot of
girls might not yeah i'm not i'm not
gonna be your housemate i'm not a slave
but here's the thing like do you want to
be happy or do you want to be alone you
know right
a lot of men need women to take care of
them wow interesting
i mean i'll take care of them cool not
take care of them but you know clean up
after them
you know cook for them and stuff like
that if he does it back
so uh i would say a woman adds value
because um
think about this right if you have
options as a guy and
there's many girls there how does that
girl stand out and i feel like
at some point because you can't just oh
no for she's gonna be wifey so you gotta
better for a period of time
we see at least one year right at least
one year vetting her for wifey um status
but you're gonna know some things up
front to see okay you know what
they said they have to get to know a
girl for a year before they'll date her
or marry wait you're ready to see the
actual potential so i'll say this
a woman that's going to be um peace of
mind so when i come from work or like
you know i'm saying
uh business call whatever there's no
arguments it's just we're just cool and
we're vibing
we talk about you know future plans and
[ __ ] like that and then secondly
i would say a woman has values and has
character because a lot of women
nowadays
all they can do is literally twerk and
they have no other value and look i mean
it's cool
i'll smash you but i never wife you up
and then thirdly a woman that helps
people in my business as well so adding
value so let's say
i have the podcast here with myron um
you know i'm gonna need my
my full my clothes folded you know what
i'm saying i'm not worried she's doing
that so just adding value in different
ways
and that's how you stand up because most
girls in america especially they don't
stand out at all
they just come through smash and then
that's it and then it goes like oh why
are you single because uh
that's i don't know why these three or
fours you know what i'm saying so
yeah like recently um i in her doing a
podcast and i had a girl she was
uh standing my place and she um had food
ready and she had drinks ready and she
was just waiting there you go i'm home
i'm like oh [ __ ]
and then you know she's gonna go in the
club and everything but i mean i think
that goes both ways just people
appreciate the little things like a lot
people really appreciate
when you do small things even
my mom would always say how much it
meant when like my dad would like
help her with like i remember when i was
a kid my dad
um i just remember this time we were at
a funeral and my dad literally like
carried my mom
to the car so she wouldn't get it like
muddy or something
like my dad's so helpful like no i'm
gonna say hey wait for you and then
afterwards you know
we can do whatever so and then what
happens is if you're like that i'm gonna
take you on trips yeah i wanna take you
oh i'm like you know what inviting you
because now you're adding value you know
what
you deserve to be treated like a not
queen but you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
i think uh it depends on what caliber
what are we talking what kind of caliber
man are we talking here that you want to
that you're trying to get just i just
want to know generally
you know what men yeah just you know
what would
what would you consider like wifey
just initially meeting her or
even just getting to know her what would
set her apart
from just somebody that again like you
want you want to have on the side or
that you want to mess with
versus somebody that you actually want
to keep
next to you and build with yeah so uh
just i hate to use you as an example
miss portuguese but like i i was
listening i've been listening very
closely to
everything that the ladies have been
saying and um an example
i would say this a lot of women
especially modern-day women
are extractors and don't necessarily add
value back
and what i mean by that a lot of women
put them the onus on the man to impress
her
so for example you know that's a big pic
on you but a lot of women think that
when i
and i champion you for being honest
because a lot of women think that way i
need you to pay for the date i need you
to
like be i need you to basically be a
traditional man which is okay
nothing wrong with that i i think that
that's the way it should be because
that's the way it's worked
for generations however women want men
to be traditional men while they can
absolve themselves of being traditional
women
and they can be modern women and that's
the problem is that they want you to be
you know slay the dragon get the money
come back
you know be a you know be chivalrous
while i don't necessarily have to be a
lady
and that's where a lot of guys are not
taking a lot of modern-day women
seriously because they understand that
why am i going to be a traditional guy
when her roles are negotiable
minor static it's not fair yeah i've
heard this
as a common complaint that basically
like girls are like oh i don't need a
man i can make my own money
[Music]
and then they still want guys to pay for
stuff
it's like they can show you guys are
waking up to this and realizing if i can
why buy the cow when i can get the milk
free as you said right
so we have a hookup culture now because
women created it
and the sad thing is is i would say that
it
has been worse for women than it has
been for men
the like the con like the
evolution of birth control has had more
negative repercussions for women than
men
because i don't think women are really
meant
to have multiple partners so i would say
for for women to stand out
you got to be able to add value to his
life not necessarily look at it like
let me add value to my life let me get
the trips let me extract resources
because a lot of women are very good at
extracting resources time and attention
from men
and some kind of compliance for for them
to give sex so i say you need to add
value first
and when a woman does that it sets you
apart from all the other women because a
lot of modern day women are taught
get what you can out of them but when
you actually add value first make his
life easier and be a compliment to his
life
make it easier and not harder you're
going to be memorable for that so and i
hate to say it ladies i know it's going
to sound [ __ ] up but
little things cleaning up the place uh
having food ready uh being a traditional
woman and i know a lot of women like to
shame that and say i'm not your mom or
whatever it may be
well if you want him to be uh a leader
and be able to provide for you and all
this other stuff you need to make his
life easier so that he can be even
better at being the provider if that
makes sense
um and that's what it is man and then
also being cooperative and submissive
you know a lot of modern-day women don't
like the word submissive they think it's
[ __ ] up
well submission only occurs by uh
consent you have to
the way that i look at submission is
it's not really
like you're giving up you're saying
everything it's more like
follow the leader like you're not the
captain of the team choose to be
submissive you know what i mean
no and being a captain of a t like i've
only been a captain once or twice
in my career but i hated it
it's so much more fun to be on the team
and not have to make the big decisions
not saying you got to submit to every
guy you know some guys are losers and
not worthy
of you know being followed but you know
that's on you as the woman to figure out
if the guy is worthy or not and i think
that's why i think it's so important we
discussed this yesterday why the father
is so important
because a dad is an amazing screening
tool an asset to help you find a guy
that's worthy
because guys will tell you sweet
nothings or whatever it may be oh i
could do this i could do that
that's really gonna put him to his
[ __ ] paces you know what i'm saying
uh
and that's the importance of of the
father but the father has been kind of
removed from the household let alone you
know helping his daughter find a mate
so and most girls don't ever talk with
their dad about who the [ __ ] they're
dating which i think women need to start
doing that because
the only man that's not going to lie to
you in your life are your brother and
your father because they're not trying
to [ __ ] you
period nope so you know you might want
to start getting these guys involved in
your dating selection
huh i never thought about doing that too
but i would say to you know
being being a traditional woman is what
is required if you want a traditional
man to be there for you
right so that's what i say but i
actually disagree with the manosphere i
don't
i've seen a lot of relationships work
that aren't quote unquote traditional
and the man of sphere makes it seem like
only 10 to 15
of relationships can work which isn't
true in the slightest it's like 50 stay
married
so i don't know my two it's funny that
you say that because i told fresh that
i grew up hearing a lot of gr i grew up
hearing a lot of the things that you
guys say for my cousins and my uncles
and my brother
same exact thing that you guys said and
you know to me keep it real
yeah to me back then it sounded so um
misogynistic and harsh exactly but now
you know i'm older and i understand that
it's true um men haven't changed
much over the centuries women have
though you know as women have made more
money become
more independent become more assertive
etc women are the ones that have changed
and since women have changed they think
men have changed too and we really
haven't we're the same like you know i
mean like men are
very very simple creatures it's the
women that have that
you know make things very difficult
because the divorces are initiated by
women not by men
you know what i'm saying so it is what
it is so i would say you know just
understanding that men are simple and
fulfilling his needs another thing i
would say is being coachable
like understanding that uh you know what
there's a void in your in your situation
here let me fill that void without even
having to be asked
you know what i'm saying or being
amenable to learning from him about what
he wants
that's gonna make you like that's how a
girl that's like a six
lands a high-value guy and keeps him as
a husband
and when these other dimes can't do it
you know what i'm saying because
being hot will get you the guy but is it
going to keep you is it going to help
you keep the guy
probably not right you know what i'm
saying they're not willing to put in the
work yeah so that's that's what it is
man cool but have you ever been
and this is the one thing that you
realize quickly as a woman is that looks
fade and the girls that have only relied
on their looks in order to get things
it goes away quick like i'm only 24 and
i'm already starting to feel
i'll feel it a little attracted to
somebody that
you know is very good looking and has
also
been a traditional woman or has taken
care of you
but yet you still don't want to wife her
yeah i mean you could find a girl that's
everything but you're not very rare to
find that though mentally you're not
ready for her like a chick that's bad
that's also going to be a traditional
woman almost never does that happen
i met a few just i wasn't ready for it
yeah
very rarely does that happen man like we
tell guys on this podcast too like
chicks that are like dimes and like
models and [ __ ] like that nine out of 10
times man like
through the streets because they like
more opportunity right like more
opportunity
tends to and plus they're in miami so i
would venture to say that if they went
to different like more than midwest or
like
suburbs small towns like they would find
a lot different types of girls but where
they're in miami so that's like party
central
and half the half of who you are is your
environment
person i say men are as faithful as
their options but women too bruh like if
once a woman gets a certain level of
being attractive like
she's just gonna get offers from certain
types of men and a lot of girls that are
young and attractive like
don't have the the maturity or the or
the knowledge
to discern a guy that wants to use them
for sexual pleasure versus the guy who's
going to take them serious so
i do like what he said though where he
said that he just wasn't mentally ready
some guys yeah some guys some guys may
not be okay i think i get the idea
uh this was interesting let me know in
the comments what you guys think
what makes a girl quote unquote wife
worthy to you
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel i'll talk to you guys
next time